of Jonah's now is the author a B
Longstaff welcome to you indeed 90 years
old who the thought is no yeah I'm
someone who's quite shocked to find out
he was 90 years old I remember reading
his books as a child why do you think
he's managed to have such enduring
appeal I think as our Tilda's author
you're always looking to appeal both to
the child at the parent and this book
does exactly that you can read it almost
any age on the surface it seems a simple
story about a group of friends told very
much from a child's point of view with
very simple child problems but
underneath there's a sort of depth to it
and I think that's what adults like
about it you know people often quoted
they you know have little inspirational
quick cards from it and it does have
that kind of depth of feeling and
sentiment and heart that you don't
always get in small children it also has
the advantage I mean it's set in sort of
fictional lash down forest but it it
doesn't date does it this relationship
between the characters it could happen
today yes me I think it's because it's
so grounded in reality it really is a
child's problems you can imagine him
playing with his toys and imagining that
they're real and each character is based
on one of the little boys toys in your
life that's right yeah and as we heard
earlier the characters are very very
well done we could all imagine someone
who's a bit like a tiger in a bit like a
Kengo and everything and I think that's
part of it but the new book is fantastic
for that it really brings together the
old original stories that's gonna give
you if you think it works Queen I mean
obviously there is a commercial motive
as really we were saying there but you
you you think it's okay yeah I think
basically it's very funny it's such a
draws on a lot of little hints from the
old books and I think if you love the
books of the child you you'd recognize
some of the things they talked about
like the North Pole Lord mentioning
going to see Buckingham Palace and
changing the guard and and I think the
books quite clever to reference that
because you know it was written back in
the nineteen twenties and and this new
book has brought it all the way around
to even having Prince George in it it's
risky sometimes though isn't it taking a
classic and reworking it sometimes you
worry that maybe they should've just
left it alone it won't be as good yeah I
think it must be terrifying there's an
author to do it I've never done it you
know I think it's hard to take someone's
work and write in their voice because
everyone has their own voice and it must
be
for the illustrator as well wait deke is
of course what the new book can't have
is the famous illustrations by Shepard
which were very much part of it success
yes but I think marks drawings do have
that lightness of touch that yet Shepard
had in the new in the Newburgh and and
they are very beautiful and there's some
gorgeous scenes of London it's lovely
seeing them travel on the bus and see
Big Ben in the background and things
it's really beautifully done and
apparently the Queen as well a fan of
the new one it's by someone called Jane
reordan and it's illustrated by Mark
Burgess and Jamie Orton what's the books
are she written I don't know her I don't
really know him afraid but a challenge
yes I think she's a children's writer
yes where do you think Whitney the Pooh
Hospital corner the influence has gone I
mean what would you sort of if you drew
the kind of family tree of 20th century
21st century children's writing a very
influential yes I think it was one of
the early books that really looked at
things from a child's point of view and
before that children's books they were
often adults books just read to children
and they were very heavy with morals and
things like fairy tales and we neither
poo and then later ones like where the
wild things are and things began began
to be more from that child-centric angle
and that was what's quite appealing
about it for children and it would be
the pure influence yourself as a writer
well I write more sort of fairy tale and
mythology based I I'm always drawn to
the fantasy and you know there are new
dragons flying around they wouldn't
appear but I love the way the animals
come to life and I think their character
representation is fantastic he's your
favorite character we're seeing those
two them there on the screen now I love
I love Tigger he's always happy bouncing
around always happy it's not it's
something really nice about that I quite
like piglet I don't know why but I think
pickle it's quite sweet what about you
Adam alright thank you very much thank
you